[Music]
in a way the problem partly of Blair was
that it was too much a Metropolitan
project I think that was almost
inevitable because of the makeup of
Parliament not including the Labour
Party including the immediate history
behind I think it was inevitable that
there was going to be an effort to try
and sell the project in ways that had
not been done before
I am very strongly against over selling
and trying to blow something up in a way
that then disappoints people and ends up
with people distrustful and and
suspicious but I do think there's
nothing wrong with actually being really
good at selling your message so in the
early days I thought Alastair Campbell
had got it right that why should we send
letters and faxes when there was
something called email why shouldn't we
actually have a narrative that people
could understand that that was a good
bit of it the bad bit is when the
message is all that you've got do you
think there was a moment you knew when
the message was the message yes when I
heard people saying things that were
completely inflated that I knew were not
deliverable and we're the resource
wasn't there I'll give you one example I
like Gordon a lot I mean it's quite
difficult person to to be with but I got
on with him quite well but he would
always round up the amounts of money
that he was announcing in the budget in
3-year tranches so he denounced that
there was going to be an increase of 21
billion in health but actually it was
six billion nine billion 11 billion that
doesn't quite add up but you get the
picture and he did it with education I
just said to God don't do it if we're
going to increase education spending by
nine billion
in three years time that's pretty good
you don't have to round it up to 15
billion by putting the songs together
otherwise you you know people are not
deaf they know that if I said I'm going
to pay you a hundred and fifty thousand
pounds fill it and actually the first
year I was only going to pay your forty
thousand you'd feel a bit fraud Ian you
know badly done by wouldn't you for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you